it's great to welcome to the program
today David Wallace wells who's a
national fellow at the New America
Foundation columnist and deputy editor
at New York magazine and author of the
book the uninhabitable earth David get
great to talk to you today appreciate
your time thanks so much for having me
it's great talk to you so let's just
dive right into it increasingly there
have been both sort of sober and
specific claims about how long until the
earth may become inhabitable what an
uninhabitable 'ti means like what do we
really mean when we say that and there
have also been some sort of very erratic
caricature is a shion's
of some of the claims that have been
made about this that are often not based
in science so if we're even going to
start thinking about this issue like
what would it mean for the earth to be
uninhabitable what are the metrics or
how should we be thinking about what
that would even look like or mean how
would we know if the earth was quote
uninhabitable well technically it was me
and that no humans were able to live on
it and I think that we're very very far
from having that be the situation we're
living in I mean probably even in a
complete worst-case scenario where
everything goes
absolutely haywire and we don't do
anything to adjust our consumption
patterns of production of carbon we're
probably talking about several centuries
at the absolute fastest so it's not a
scenario that is coming in the near term
but what is coming quite close is the
devastation of particular parts of the
planet many of which are now quite
densely inhabited which could make them
much much harder to live in so as soon
as 2050 many scientists who study the
direct heat effects of global warming
which is to say literally how much the
human body can take how much temperature
in humanity the human body can take
before risking heatstroke and possibly
heat death say that many of the biggest
cities in South Asia and the Middle East
would be so hot in summer that you
wouldn't really be able to go outside
during the day you certainly wouldn't be
able to work outside during the day
without risking heatstroke and these are
cities that today hold 10 12 15 million
people and it's possible that as soon as
2050 which may sound a little far away
but is you know just the length of an
American mortgage from now those cities
would literally not be able to support
human life in the way that man
standard today which is one reason why
the UN expects that also by 2050 we
could have as many as 200 million
climate refugees or possibly more right
so what we're talking about in a sense
is the under estimating that is taking
place as to the effects of climate
change when we're talking about
habitability we're talking about parts
of the planet we're talking about in
particular ways I mean some that I think
of our sea-level rise putting certain
cities underwater it's not the earth is
uninhabitable but it's we are sort of
being pushed further inland in some
sense when we talk about pollution from
industrialization and continued burning
of fossil fuels it's not uninhabitable
but it's how much technology are we
going to need just to be able to breathe
when we go outdoors or will we not be
able to go outdoors at a certain point
what are some of the other ways that in
the immediate we should be thinking
about these restraints on the
habitability of parts of the planet well
actually air pollution is one that I
find really striking there is a major
study I talked about a lot in 2018
looking at just the difference between
1.5 degrees of warming and 2 degrees of
warming and to give your your audience a
sense we're already at one point one
degrees of warming above the what's
called the pre-industrial average that
puts us already outside the entire
window of temperatures that enclose all
of human history so the earth is now
already warmer than it's ever been
during the entire history of humanity
stretching back all through the time in
which we evolved we developed
agriculture and civilization and modern
civilization so that you can think of
really everything we know about human
life is having developed under climate
conditions that already are out of date
that's where we are now one point one
degrees of warming and we're on track
for about four point three degrees of
warming but just between one point five
degrees and two degrees the science is
estimated just through the impact of air
pollution which is not narrowly a result
of climate change but it's produced by
the same thing that produces climate
change which is to say the burning of
fossil fuels the estimated air pollution
would kill 153 million additional people
and you know when I tell that to
audiences when I tell it to interviewers
when I tell it to friends there
cases go ashen their eyes go why they
think my god this is a completely
unconscionable level of suffering its
death of scale of twenty five Holocaust
and they're right it is unconscionable
and yet nine million people are already
dying every year from the effects of air
pollution so we're already turning away
from some of these impacts today even
though we might like to think that we
could we wouldn't turn away from them
then we would find the money you know a
moral obligation to address them we see
already that we're dealing with many of
these impacts without doing much to
address them at all and you know take
another example I recently wrote a piece
about in finance magazine about the
California wildfires
I spoke to Eric Garcetti the mayor of LA
he's 48 years old the year he was born
60,000 acres of forest burned in
California the year he was elected mayor
2013 it was 600,000 a tenfold increase
the year he was re-elected mayor in 2017
it was 1.2 million acres which means
twice as much as had just been the case
for years before and last year 2018 1.9
million acres burned these trajectories
are inescapable to anyone who lives in
California and the scientists say that
again just by 2050 which is again you
know if you're buying a home in
California it's just the length of a
mortgage from now just by 2050
scientists expect that wildfires will
get at least twice as bad and maybe four
times as bad as they are now and asked
in the second half of the century the
estimates are even more dramatic there
are some responsible science I think
it's a little high so there's some
responsible science that says that by
the end of the century 2100 wildfires in
California could get 64 times worse
which would mean something like 75
percent of the state of California would
be burning every single year now again I
think that there are reasons to think
that those numbers are a little high but
they give you a sense of just how
dramatically transformed the planet can
be by even one of these impacts and
there are so many that you can't even
count them you know hurricanes extreme
weather drought famine the public health
issues that arise when mosquitoes that
used to be trapped in the tropics are
flying as far north of the Arctic Circle
as will be the case very shortly
there's a relationship between
temperature and war so that forever we
have to grieve warming those who study
it suggest that we would get between 10
and 20 percent increases
so if we end up at four degrees at the
end of the century which is what while
I'm traffic world we could have twice as
much we have today and there's a major
impact on economic growth so that by the
end of the century 2100 we could be
dealing with at least 20% smaller
perhaps 30% smaller global GDP and we
would have without climate change 30
percent isn't impact that's twice as big
as the Great Depression and it would be
permanent
there would be parts of the planet that
would be hit by six climate or the
natural disasters at once so this is a
sort of inescapable all-encompassing
threat I look at these impacts and they
seem really dramatic they seem
terrifying as they should be
I also think that we'll find a way to
adapt and live among some of these
impacts but what it will mean for the
way that we organize our societies the
way that we organize our politics how
much empathy we extend to those around
the world these are really big open
questions I think they may be as
profound as the ones about direct
climate impact and we haven't really yet
begun to think about just how scrambled
our lives will be by this force which is
I think as big and all-encompassing the
force as say modernity was in the
nineteenth century or you know you could
say financial capitalism was in the late
20th it will dominate the coming century
in ways that we don't even yet know how
to anticipate when I cover this stuff I
want to be as precise and accurate as
possible as someone who lives in the
United States about how bad or not bad
of an actor the u.s. climate skepticism
climate denial sort of status quo is in
the grand scheme of things and there are
obviously lots of reasons to think that
the United States is a bad actor here
and acutely so there are some defenses
like for example listen most of the
carbon is not being burned in the u.s.
even though disproportionately it is
being burned in the u.s. in sort of raw
numbers it's not the u.s. is just one
player even though these other countries
are doing some stuff they're still just
trying to slow the growth of the problem
rather than actually reduce the size of
the problem how bad of an actor is the
US and all of this it really depends on
your perspective so you know I think
it's important for everyone to
understand the u.s. is now producing
about 15 percent of carbon emissions
globally that puts us in the second
second place which is not a good place
to be but China is producing about twice
as much there
28% of global carbon emissions today
that's one perspective but another
perspective is historically so how much
we're responsible for putting the carbon
up in the atmosphere to begin with and
from that perspective we the u.s. is
responsible for actually but I think the
majority of all carbon emissions that
have ever been produced by humanity so
in that sense we have a kind of there's
a moral imperative for us to act even if
today we're doing better than than some
other nations in the world in terms of
you know denial and skepticism I
personally think that those forces are
completely villainous I think that the
fossil fuel companies are doing great
damage to on the future of the planet
and the way that they've captured at
least you know the perspective of one of
the two parties in the u.s. is a tragedy
and an outrage
on the other hand when you look around
the world at countries that where fossil
fuel interests have much less of a put
have much less political power yes and
governments that are much more committed
to green policies and at least
rhetorically basically none of them are
doing any better in terms of reducing
carbon emissions than the u.s. is and
that makes me think that the problem
here may be a bit deeper than simply the
force of denial or you know or climate
skepticism and that we may be
distracting ourselves and sort of given
ourselves a pat on the back when we when
we need it as an American liberal when
we point the finger at the other side
and say it's all their fault I think you
know the UK is doing a bit better than
the u.s. is on there a few countries in
the EU that we're doing a little bit
better but I you know it's generally
speaking we signed the Paris Accords
three years ago all of the countries of
the world
no major country in the world is on
track to meet those commitments right
even if all of them did we'd still be on
track for north of three degrees of
warming this century which would be
completely catastrophic you know by
almost every metric the only nations in
the entire world that are even
compatible at this point with the goals
of the Paris Accords are Morocco and
Gambia two countries that's it so I
think we're dealing with a much much
bigger problem than simply the force of
denial in the US you know and and and
the way that the Republican Party has
been captured by those forces on the
other hand I don't want to let those
people off the hook because I think they
are very much fighting the wrong side of
history
and doing doing a kind of moral damage
to the country and the world even if
practically speaking I think that their
their role is a bit overstated sometimes
so you said a few minutes ago that you
do think that in the face of all of
these coming negative consequences that
we will in many ways find ways to cope
but I want to sort of go a step further
than that which is to say is the fact
that you chose to have a kid while
writing this book a sign that in a more
general sense you're optimistic that
this is something humans will deal with
appropriately I think of myself as an
optimist yes I mean I think it's really
important to keep in mind what we're -
think about what you're basing your
expectations off of so if you're hoping
that the world is going to stay roughly
as it is today which is already a quite
degraded climate where 3 5 into 100 year
storms and hits you still in the last
three years well we've had those
catastrophic wildfires these
unprecedented heat waves you know the
biggest storm in 50 years to hit
Mozambique followed by the big bigger
storm less than a month later all these
kinds of impacts that are would have
been unconscionable just a generation
ago we're already in that kind of
unprecedented heroine climate situation
and if you're hoping to preserve this
climate that terrible damage climate
even that I think is hopeless there's no
way that we're going to stabilize the
climate and anything like our present
situation which means from that
perspective you know that's a strong
argument for pessimism but I like to
think that our best baseline of
expectation is the track we're headed on
which is to say 4 degrees of warming and
I think there's quite a lot that we can
do and will do to avert that level of
warming I think it's really important to
keep in mind when I talk about some of
these really catastrophic impacts of
wildfires the economic impacts that
twice as much war all that stuff these
impacts can seem overwhelmingly large
but they're also a reminder that we have
power of the climate they're a
reflection of our power of the climate
if we get to that 4 degree of level and
we're dealing with all of those impacts
it will be because of what we do from
here through the end of the century that
means that our hands are on those levers
and we can theoretically change course
theoretically there are a lot of human
obstacles in the way that are preventing
us or at least slowing down that action
but theoretically it's up to us to write
the story of this
future and I think you know part of the
reason I had a child I think partly it's
that I'm living in delusion and
compartmentalization like so many other
people and want to live my life as I
want to live it as some of the other
people do not thinking about these
issues but to the extent that I was
focused on the climate question and
thinking about the choice to have a
child I think you know I was very
mindful of the fact that this story is
not yet written it is up to us to write
it and a huge range of outcomes are
possible from a little bit worse than we
have today to quite dramatically worse
and I think on climate as with
everything you have to fight for the
kind of world that you want to live in
and you want your loved ones to live
living rather than giving up before the
story has even been written has been
determined and I think for all for all
those reasons I think it's up to us and
we should you know see the use the
opportunities for optimism and for
action
rather than we're treating it's a
fatalism in despair because the truth is
even though the climate as we know it
today is already already gone there's no
hope for saving it the story is not at
all over yet and we fall into a trap
often thinking of climate as a binary
system where it's either
there's no climate change or climate
changes here or you know it's livable or
catastrophic but it's a spectrum and
every tick upward of temperature that we
get it's gonna make life worse with more
pain and more suffering around the world
most of it concentrated in the global
south but every tick upward that we can
avoid means that life will be better
healthier more prosperous and I think we
owe it to all of us and you know our
children and grandchildren to fight for
the future as much as we can every day
the book is called the uninhabitable
earth we've been speaking with the
book's author David Wallace wells who's
also a national fellow at the New
America Foundation and colonist and a
deputy editor at New York Magazine David
really appreciate your time today thanks
so much for having me great to talk to
you